les cas c'est 20 millions
[Applaudissements]
arnaud montebourg rappelé à l'ordre par
la direction du ps pour une plaisanterie
sur les talonnettes de sarkozy bah oui
mais bon l'humoriste maison au ps et
georges frêche chacun son boulot
international joyeux noël 80 % des
jouets vendus en france proviennent des
usines chinoises coûts de fabrication
d'une barbie 0,35 centimes d'euro bon
cela dit comme ce sont des enfants qui
les assemble le temps qu'ils les
montrent ils en profitent
international toujours 25 français
présents à l'hôtel holiday inn and co a
été empoisonné au polonium
qui sont ils des noms circulent barthez
fabian quoss jean-pierre et blanc michel
social campagne anti sida johnny
hallyday nous questionnent est ce que
vous aimeriez autant ma gueule si
j'étais séropositif bah oui bien sûr ici
ça nous pose aucun problème
cela dit dans une petite station de
sports d'hiver suisse où tout le monde
se connaît ça risque des prisons merde
social toujours la bonne action de
laeticia hallyday acheter un ange
marionnaud pour aider les enfants
défavorisés
quand un résident suisse vous donne un
conseil de charité publique écoutez le
le directeur de décathlon est fier que
ses tantes soit en ville une phrase
prononcée déjà par bertrand delanoë lors
de la gay pride
sport soixante quatorze supporters
blessé lors d'un match de foot à dakar
le psg porte plainte pour plagiat
télévision nathalie marquay la femme de
jean pierre pernaut pourrait animer un
magazine de jardinage juste avant le jt
de son mari nathalie à la main verte
lors de l'été 2005 qu'elle est partie en
classe nature avec daniel ducruet au
programme binage labour à l'épluchage de
coire où
mon côté grosse tête
marie drucker attire les curieux depuis
la révélation de sa liaison avec
françois baroin 600000 personnes de plus
ont regardé son jt bien aussi si
ardisson coup cheikh michèle alliot
marie on gagnerait des téléspectateurs
fin thierry c'est un petit effort on
l'attraper avec son étole et crack un
nom une relation extra terrestres non
c'est noël si vous détestez un membre de
votre famille offrait le nouvel album de
mimie mathy écrit par patrick fiori
double peine
cadeau pourri toujours l'intégrale de la
fontaine récité par luchini pour faire
chier sa belle-mère n'y a pas mieux et
puis à quelques jours de noël scandale
dans le monde magique de la bd lors du
tournage d'astérix aux jeux olympiques
des [ __ ] aurait été fournie sur le film
c'est pas grave faut juste changer le
nom des acteurs saudeau mix éjacule hic
c'est qu'une ilan x
[Applaudissements]
on termine avec le magazine gala qui
célèbre les bébés de l'année celui de
tom cruise de la rue angelina jolie en
revanche rien sur les trois bébé
d'isabelle courjault trois bébés
congelés sur papier glacé ça aurait eu
de la gueule une certaine frilosité chez
gala
joyeux noël à tous et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus